comprendre athe je
c'est un agent fédéral au cul serré c'est
le meilleur flic de Paul Feig le directeur
des demoiselles d'honneur dont le FBI a compétence
sait qu'elle cherche mes couilles hé si
quelqu'un voit les couilles du capitaine, faites-moi
savoir qu'ils sont à peu près aussi gros qu'ils sont comme
vraiment très petites balles de petite fille si les
petites filles avaient des balles je suis un
enquêteur qualifié oh nous pourrions entrer et les
battre avec une balle en mousse vous avez juste besoin d'
être patient marcher sans réservoir il y a des tonnes de
liens avec le monde de la drogue là c'est
toi  ne t'intègre pas je suis un agent fédéral
vraiment parce que tu as l'air de
vouloir installer une table pour faire leurs [ __ ] d'impôts
chérie Thomas arrête ça ils sont Spanx ils
tiennent tout ensemble
pourquoi ce qui va arriver [ __ ]
de
surprise
je  Je ne peux pas te tenir le cul droit Puma non attends
je ne plaisante plus vraiment je ne peux pas
soulever une voiture en métal a cassé sa chute bien
ouais
secouons ça Sandra Bullock
comme on le fait dans la rue mot ne
t'argot pas  c'est comme regarder une
nonne s'embrasser  Mfortable hein Melissa
McCarthy gentille grande pour toi ma chérie
qui est-ce que ma mère n'a pas de téléphones portables en ce
moment
Oh une histoire différente
qui était plutôt géniale